ah
[music]
ah ah
[music] The
old impression that gives is a
different world
I can imagine and think
that there is room to add an empty world beyond that
[music]
sephora
spiders
that
woo
The most important thing to me when designing is
to find Tom
[Music]
1 The Earl and lifestyle that our ancestors wore.
[Music] The
tailoring itself
is very different from what we wear in our daily life.  Wouldn't it be a little more valuable in the future by using almost the same material as it
is, simpler and
more Korean?
When making hanbok, the material is very
important.
I imagine a
thing. Let's touch it
. The reason I came to wear hanbok is to write what I like the most
. In the
past, there was nothing Korean that I liked. The
thing that
touched me is the moon jar
.
Looking at the process and the jar, I
just bury it. Should I just bury it? Oh, it comes down like that? The
moon jar is
not natural and warm
, and I have a
lot of room.  When new things come,
I can criticize them, but
while looking positively at the reasons why they make things like this, I
try to open up
yesterday's design
to me as well.  It's uh uh
[music]  ]